it's one thing to do a marvel movie
because listen i'm an mcu nerd i'll just
say it off the top um but then you bring
chloe zahl's vision into this is that
what kind of sold it for you in a way or
made it maybe even more special for you
doing a film with her it was certainly
something that when when chloe says i
want it to be a love letter to earth i
want it to be this kind of a family for
these reasons i she's somebody you can
you can trust isn't saying that to
because it sounds right as a director
you know that she will live and breathe
it and she will deliver on it
and then when they told me what the
intention was what the family was
i felt it was a long time coming that
this
i think there's been so many kind of
great things about
this film one of the things that i love
that's come out of it is this you talk
about it being a love letter to earth
but i kind of feel like you and selma
have like found a love and really found
a sisterhood that i think is so cool
yeah and lauren and everybody there's a
whole group of us yeah how much did you
really enjoy that birthday cake smash in
salmon's basketball were you yeah
i don't
no i mean it's fun but i didn't you know
i loved my girl i didn't i wasn't it
wasn't easy to stick her face and cake
you're like am i really so you really
want me to do this
so good um leah you know sprite leah
said that you and salma were kind of
like the ring leaders for all of the
offset activities like right getting
people together making them feel
comfortable you do that a lot on sets i
hear that a lot from especially the
younger actors that you work with why do
you do that so much
i'm a mom
so that's my my thing
speaking of i heard your kids were shook
by your costume i mean would you want to
see your mother wearing that
[Laughter]
listen if you got it you got it
they were like
i don't know i think they're still they
haven't seen the movie so i think
they're gonna but i mean your mom walks
in in a full spandex gold outfit with
gold hair and you just think what do you
do for a living what are you
how do you get back in your robe my kids
are all mixed with like vintage and my
old oscars these are my old oscar dress
no where where is she
but they weaved it all vintage and like
upcycled my old stuff i love that
so by the way you do have your your new
book coming out and it's all about
you know
being tolerant and you know teaching
those things to your kids and yeah and
their rights so you know was was that
kind of a love letter to your kids doing
this book
it was certainly in part for my kids
because i think they need to understand
their rights and and uh
and and the lack of and how
you know we talk a lot about we have
rights people have rights children have
rights but then we see all these abuses
around the world so i wanted to do a
real study
of what does that mean and
do we really have them
how do we get them if we don't have them
what are we supposed to have and what
are they based on and we know that
they're based on especially for children
these are rights that
are there because this is what would
make a self a safe and balanced
child and without these fundamentals it
would be hard for this child to have a
stable healthy life right
but a lot of children don't access those
rights and so it's a it's a base
i don't know where you are but i love
you too
people are out they you know what there
is a different kind of fan love that you
get from the marvel universe are you
ready for that kind of fan life
i'll take it i'm grateful and i'll take
it i love this i'm a marvel fan so
ready i know this movie you know in in
the comics the eternals is really kind
of different so
we're expecting i don't know what i'm
gonna expect from this
i know i feel like we should do this
after you guys see the movie so you can
tell us um it's i think it's i think
it's different yeah it's different
[Music]